hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are continuing
the coverage of the match Fabiana karana
versus Magnus Carlsen from round 3 and
Fabiano is down two points so he needs
to win both games on demand in order to
well I'll get back into the match
enforce an Armageddon and it's I don't
know it's incredibly difficult
regardless of who were playing against
but it's even more difficult when you
are playing against the world champion
so let's see how far we does and the
wheel Magnus stick to his audience
defense from round one so Fabi repeats
efore obviously sorry about that
obviously ready for another round of the
islands defense but the Magnus replies
with E 5 and here we're gonna have a
very interesting line night of three
night the c6
we have Bishop to b5 and now a six so
now Murphy's defense to the real Lopez
Bishop to a4 night to have sex with
castles and b5 now we have Bishop to b3
and here Magnus probably somewhat
surprises Fabi he goes for the
Arkhangelsk with the Bishop to c5 move
which is a fabi's main weapon in the
candidates tournament so obviously
challenging Fabi where he is strongest
so let's see how far he deals with it we
have a four which is the usual reply you
wanna challenge this upon here rook to
b8 and now there already was a game in
this line in the candidates tournament
Alexander Grich who played it against
Fabiana corwin agree she went c3 here
and they drew their game but here Fabi
continues with a capture son b5 instead
eight chapters in we go for the
simplification line Knight captures on
e5 Knight captures and mount d4 I think
we already covered it at least two times
on the channel there's AB character son
before Queen captures and now just b6
defending in the night with f4 Knight to
c6 and the Queen to c3 now attacking the
knight we have Knight the e7 and
rook to a7 out by Fabi so this has all
been played before so especially for
Fabi who prepared this variation for the
candidates tournament this is a very
very simple stuff we have c5 by Magnus
and the e5 now with Knight to e4
attacking the Queen
and now there are a few games work
winter you want was played but here we
have Queen to f3 by Fabi and it is as a
move 16 that we have a completely new
game so Magnus replies with d5 he
defends his night and the Fabia
continues with c3 although he didn't it
takes some time here it is a complicated
position and that there is this tricky
Bishop characters and b5 but it requires
too much calculation and if Fabi isn't
sure about it then you just don't go for
it because after Queen captures rook to
d1 now the Queen has to keep an eye on
the night and if the Queen moves for
example anywhere other than maybe c6 or
c4 to defend the night it's gonna be
really crazy and the the best line is
obviously Queen to c4 and this after b3
Queen captures here Knights the a3 and
now you will win back the night after
the Queen moves somewhere let's say
Queen if to check captures captures
captures and now let's say Bishop to g4
going after the rook the game continues
but it's a it's a really crazy crazy
position yeah so if you're not sure
about it you don't touch this pawn so
instead see three by five e and c4 now
by Magnus pushing the bishop back Bishop
c2 and now Bishop to g4 immediately
saying that if you capture the bishop
right away then I have Queen b6 check
winning at the buzzer winning the rook
here although maybe it's not such a bad
deal for Fabi for example King here you
capture the rook and now you eliminate
the night and to start pushing f5 and
it's going to be incredibly tricky if
King castles f6 is coming so who knows
but Fabi instead goes for rook captures
on e7 instead saying that okay the the
rook will fall so I want to at least
misplace your queen or maybe even the
King captures but Magnus just captures
with the Queen and you still have this
Queen c5 check which is pretty much the
same as Queen b6 check so Queen captures
on g4 by Fabi
and now Queen the c5 with check King -
h1 and now knife 2f to check for King
the king and the Queen and the rook has
the capture night we have Queen captures
now threatening mate and now Queen back
to d1 as there's also the threat of
capturing the bishop not just made so
queen bee one are covering both and now
Magne just castles and we have this
really really weird position where
Magnus has two rooks against two bishops
and the night so Bishop to b2 Fabi has
to figure out how to get all of his
pieces into the game and now d4 just the
first threatening d3 but also just
hoping for captures and then rook to the
8th which is what Fabi plays characters
we have rook F to d8 and now Queen to c1
as you can really go for something like
a butcher of the c3 to keep an eye on
the pond because b4 and then just bishop
moves wherever you capture this point
with the rook and so on so instead after
this we have Queen to c1 and now just
before continuing to push we have Bishop
to e3 now attacking the Queen while
defending the pawn and now just Queen to
e2 so still Fabi needs to figure out how
to get his pieces into the game push her
back to g1 and now comes c3 by Magnus a
very interesting upon sacrifice but it
will make it somewhat difficult for him
to defend both the bishop and the Queen
here once the rook comes to c8 so B
captures we have B characteris Knight
captures and now we have Queen the c4
now preparing to bring the rook into the
game and hopefully win some material
Knight back to D 1 and now rugby to see
it now threatening just to win material
so you have to go for Knights to e3 but
then you no longer guard the D the d4
pawn so now Magnus captures it and here
we have Queen to f1 just getting the
Queen eyelid way hoping to start finally
getting the pieces to some optimal
squares we have Queen to d2
now just threatening to win with rook
characters and c2 so Queen the b1 again
defending is threatening on h7 and here
Magnus just defended with h6 which gives
Fabia a moment to also create some
breathing room for his own King as there
are some background issues here so rook
the c3 again Magnus earth-threatening it
two into two pieces for the rook and now
comes Queen to b6 putting pressure on
the rook here so if if you capture
danger
captures and if the Queen captures you
pick up the rock with check so Queen 2d
for Magnus now offers a queen trade he
wants to play two rooks against all of
these pieces and Quinta a five by Fabi
we worked the c5 attacking the Queen
Queen to a seven and here
Magnus goes for rook captures and c2 he
gives up the exchange two to go into a
sort of an endgame with with rook
against two pieces and here we have
Knight captures and c2 grabbing the
Queen right away it is also possible but
then rook captures and you do tray down
into this in and the unite captures
buddenbrook characters on f4 and it's
very likely that Magnus will hold this
so after rook captures and c2 we have
Knight captures and c2 instead first now
you cannot I mean you could again go for
this exact same in game but now Magnus
decides for Queen captures on f4 and now
he keeps the Queens on the board which
it's hard to say white is better with
the bishop and the night however if if
you can't consolidate and start the
moving your pieces forward here you're
not really better so Knight the d4 now
with the idea that if Queen captures on
e5 you have a tactic here just winning
the material so after 94 Queen
efore by Magnus and now comes Queen to
b6 we have looked at the five going
after the e5 pawn now and now Knight f3
defending we have looked at e3 now
threatening the just rote captors on f3
which pretty much ensures black a
perpetual as Magnus only needs a draw to
win the match now since he's leading by
two point margin so Queen to b8 with
check King to h7 and now Quinta and now
Queen back to b1 not allowing this
capture as the Queen would hang so here
Magnus goes for rook to e3 and rook to
e3 is is the one moment where he allows
fob it to take initiative in this game
probably grabbed a winning advantage
here Magnus just wants to trade Queens
but there is a move that he missed so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this idea for Fabi while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting that the
rook is under attack but also the f7
point is undefended
so here had a queen a two bin plate then
Magnus is in a really really bad
position his rook is still under attack
and also now the pawn here so you cannot
defend both you have to do something
rookie to and then just Queen captures
here and now you have a passed pawn and
it's gonna be very very hard to defend
this end on the other hand after Queen a
- you don't have route captors and I
three now because after this a queen can
just block and nothing really nothing
really going on here
so this was a great moment for Fabi
however far we missed that Fabi went for
Queen to f1 and now just look back to d3
for Magnus we have Bishop to f2 and now
rook the b3 preparing rook to be one to
hopefully win some material here so King
H - but now Queen sorry rook the b1
again with the attack on the Queen Queen
a six and now Rock the beat you
attacking the bishop here we have Quinta
a7 defending the bishop and now Queen a4
check we have King - h1 and now Queen to
c1 again with check and here Bishop to
g1 blocking this way and now Queen c2
threatening checkmate here so luckily
for Fabi there's knife to h4 to defend
the mate and now Queen efore again going
after the pawn here Queen to e7
defending not interested in trading
point for pawn and now comes Luke the b7
now Magnus gets his rook back into the
defense of the f7 pawn we have Queen to
d8 and now comes Luke the b3 if you if
you capture here then you allow this
Queen to d3 check although it's it
doesn't really do anything
so here Magnus instead just goes rook to
b3 and now we have Knight back to f3
guarding the e5 pawn we have rook
captures on f3 by Magnus and now the
queen is a bit too far to help out with
the defense GG address we have Queen
captures and now King to h2 and now
Magnus played Queen f4 check King g2 we
have Queen the e4 check TF one Queen to
f3 check we have bishop to have two
blocking and now Queen captures and h3
with Czech king g1 we have Queen to g4
check King f1 and now Queen to h3 check
King g1 to Queen g4 check and it was in
this position that Fabi and Magnus
agreed to a draw as there is no way for
Fabi to even think about winning this
game for example if he was King f1 and
he persists and going all the way to the
center that Amir is your Queen side then
Queen h5 check again wherever you go you
just lose the e5 point as well and now
it's three pawns against the bishop
which means that Magnus can comfortably
trade Queens and then play the same game
against the bishop so of course if Abby
didn't go for that after Queen to g4
check they agreed to a draw which means
that after three games
Magnus wins the match over the game 4
will also be played as it is required
for additional criteria for win the
tournament ends on deciding you know tie
breaks and stuff sure that's game 3 of
the match of Fabi versus Magnus I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank gavinc rook Joel Abram Bohol
in-market Barakat Sarah and Seth
Yarborough for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous video Sierra think'll for
watching and I will see you soon most
likely with the game 4 of their match
unless it's like a total snoozefest so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day